you know you have good times you have
bad times but i think i got a little
what's called cabin fever remember in
the shining yeah
when he's telling jack nicholson he's
like well a man um
delbert grady he was a caretaker good
man no no
uh previous records of anything violent
or anything but he brought his family up
here for the winner and uh
after a couple of months he got what
some people call
cabin fever you know just kind of lost
his mind and he
chopped his daughters up with an axe and
shot his wife with a shotgun
and uh anyway so it's not that i'm just
saying that i remember
that way you're right is it no no no no
i'm not like that i don't get violent i
just
i just sometimes wake up or i don't
really i don't sleep well i get anxious
have you gotten i know you're a pretty
mellow guy but do you do you get anxiety
um i'll tell you one thing i do
i i do and i don't i mean like i i
definitely feel
um at times sort of
anxious and overwhelmed and stuff like
that but it it's
it's not it's not debilitating in the
way that i know the actual medical
definition of it is so i would never
i would never say i have anxiety i think
it can be quite
i know it's i know it's a you know it's
a it's a heavily used term but
when i've seen people who genuinely
suffer from anxiety and it can be really
debilitating and they can't like they
don't want to get out of bed or they
don't want to leave the house or
whatever and they can't
like i mean my wife gets it sometimes
and she can't even speak you know
and it's like i would never want to
reduce that by saying oh yeah
i get anxiety like i get anxious about
things but i don't have
anxiety if that makes sense yeah um
um but i yeah absolutely i mean i get i
get certainly get
get quite overwhelmed with with the job
at times usually when i'm when i'm in
the middle of
a job and i'm panicking about it being
okay so oh wait so do you equate
success with happiness like
if you are great or like you're
you're insatiable obviously you want to
be great we all want to be great
we want the studios to think we're great
and but
uh after a while you know the older i
get to rely
i realize i just got to do the best i
can and by the way i'm not saying
i'm i'm good with this now but like
you know when is it good enough or what
what is it that makes you anxious about
that
well i think the there's there's a
couple of things so like my
my because i i was seeing a
therapist for a little while um and
it was simply because um
and again like it wasn't anything
debilitating i just thought
i think that there's not there shouldn't
be a stigma around it for a start
and i thought well i'm not working it's
i'm a bit down in the dumps i'm sort of
like
um i didn't feel um
fulfilled inspired i didn't feel
inspired to do anything i felt like i
just couldn't be bothered and even when
and it wasn't if like i was out like
self tapes were coming in i just
couldn't be bothered and i was like
what's wrong with
with this so i spoke to someone and it
was fine like it was it was all right
and uh
we came out the other end of it and
actually moving back to florida helped a
great deal
um but but she said something quite
interesting to me she said that you need
to find something
in your life that that you can do
so that you can remove your job from
from being the soul thing that defines
you
because it was like everything that i
was doing
every choice that i was making in life
um had all been to try and make
myself as successful as possible and
therefore every time that i was a
setback where i didn't get a role or
um or something wasn't as successful as
it could have been or a bad review
it was like that was all-consuming
that suddenly that was a reflection on
me as a human being not just to me as an
actor but also me as a me as my
worth as a person um and
i mean she told me that i haven't fixed
that i haven't done what she's told me
to do
yeah well
you